- Hi everyone. I am Maurice Samuels,
the Director of the Yale program
for the study of Anti-Semitism,
and it's my great pleasure to welcome you
to the first event of the
2023-24 academic year.
I was on leave last year, which was great,
but I'm also very happy to
be back hosting these events.
This year, some events
are gonna be on Zoom
and some are gonna be in person,
but we're going to be
broadcasting the live events
on Zoom as well.
So I urge everyone to check
out the YPSA calendar of events
on our website and get
on the mailing list.
I'm especially excited to
introduce today's speaker,
Martha Hodes since she
was the Interim Director
of the Doris and Lewis B. Cullman Center
for Scholars and Writers at
the New York Public Library
where I had my fellowship last year.
So I had the chance to
have many conversations
with Martha as she finished this book.
She's now back to her regular day job
as Professor of History at NYU
where she specializes in American
history of the Civil War.
She's the author of many books
including "White Women, Black Men:
"Illicit Sex in the
Nineteenth-Century South,"
"The Sea Captain's Wife: A
True Story of Love, Race,
and War in the Nineteenth
Century," and "Mourning Lincoln,"
which won the Lincoln Prize in 2016.
Actually, all of her books have won awards
and made many Best Book of the Year lists
when they were published.
Martha is a past recipient
of the Guggenheim Fellowship
and has many other distinctions
that I won't attempt to list
because I'm so eager
to hear her talk about
her fascinating new book, "My Hijacking:
A Personal History of
Forgetting and Remembering"
published by Harper
Collins this past spring.
Before I hand it over to Martha,
let me just explain how
things will work today.
Martha is gonna speak for about
35 or so minutes, I think.
Then we'll open it up to
questions from the audience.
Please submit your questions to me using
the Q&A function at the
bottom of your screen
and I'll do my best to ask
as many of them as I can.
We can't see or hear you however,
and the chat function is disabled.
So please only use the Q&A function
and you can send questions
as soon as you think of them.
You don't have to wait
for the talk to be over,
you can just start sending them to me.
Okay, so that's it for the housekeeping
and I will now hand it over to Martha.
- Thank you, thank you so much Maury
and thank you for this opportunity
to present to this group,
and I thank everybody for tuning in
everyone who's with us today.
Well, as maybe was clear
from Maury's introduction,
I've never written a book
like this one, "My Hijacking:
A Personal History of
Forgetting and Remembering."
I'm a historian of the
19th century United States
and all my other books focus
on Race and the Civil War era,
the most recent, a book
about personal responses
to Lincoln's assassination.
My Hijacking like my other books,
is based on deep archival research,
but here, I also
intertwine my own memories
and my own research into family history.
This book, for those of
you who haven't read it,
is about the hijacking of
three planes in September 1970,
the hijackers were members
of the Popular Front for
the Liberation of Palestine,
a radical Marxist-Leninist
faction, too radical
even for the Palestine
Liberation Organization, the PLO.
I was 12 years old at the time,
a passenger on one of the planes.
I was traveling with my
13-year-old sister Catherine,
and we were unaccompanied by adults.
We were returning to
New York from Tel Aviv.
My mother had moved to
Israel to help start
the Batsheva Dance Company
under the direction
of Martha Graham.
My parents were both former
principal Graham dancers
and my sister and I spent our
childhood summers in Israel
and I'm just going to share
a couple of images with you.
That's me on the left
in the summer of 1970
at my mother's Tel Aviv
apartment building,
and then my sister
Catherine and me practicing
our yoga poses on the beach.
And that photo on the right
was taken the day before
we boarded the plane home.
Catherine and I were held
hostage in the Jordan Desert
inside the airplane for a week.
Our captors hope to exchange
the passengers and crew
for Palestinian prisoners.
The book then is something of a hybrid
about my own participation if unwitting
in a world historical event.
What I'd like to do this afternoon is,
is offer to you various
parts of the manuscript
with interjections for
my listeners here today.
So to begin, I will set
the scene at the outset.
Sunday before sunrise,
everything is dark and quiet
in our Tel Aviv neighborhood.
We packed the night before and
now my mother helps us close
the tops of our identical gray suitcases.
At LAD airport, not much
more than a single building,
we come to an ascending stairway
with a big BON VOYAGE sign hanging above.
From there, travelers must proceed alone,
and when we arrive at that stairway,
my mother puts on her sunglasses.
She's crying because she
has to say goodbye to us
for a long time.
I like that memory.
Something about it
parallels my favorite book
in the summer of 1970.
My Israeli stepfather had
given us "The Little Prince"
with an intriguing cover illustration
of a young boy standing on a barren planet
with a miniature volcano.
First my stepfather read the story to us,
then I read it to myself,
enchanted by the lonely aviator narrator
whose plane crashed in the desert
and the downcast boy
wanderer he met there.
That boy, the little prince fits farewell
to a temperamental flower,
a rose he loves very much.
"Of course, I love you."
The rose tells the little prince.
"It is my fault that you have
not known it all the while."
She implores the boy to be happy
and asks him not to linger
for she did not want
him to see her crying.
I read the book twice more
until I had it nearly memorized.
In my diary I wrote, it is fantastic!
In various parts of the book then,
I interweave quotations
from the Little Prince,
which appear in the text in parentheses,
and you'll hear some of
these in the next while
as I'm speaking with you.
To continue from a bit farther on,
takeoff from Frankfurt is
right on schedule at 11:02 AM,
less than an hour later
as we soar over Belgium,
the captain announces an
altitude of 28,000 feet
with Brussels visible on the left.
I hear a commotion
shouting that sounds angry,
words I don't understand.
Now a woman is running up the aisle,
a man follows both of them shouting.
Some passengers think a husband and wife
are having a violent argument,
others that the woman is
airsick running to the bathroom
to vomit.
I see only a blur, but
Catherine sees the man's gun.
Others see the nickel plated revolver too
along with the woman's finger
inserted through the ring
of a hand grenade.
"I hope it's not the Arabs"
gasps the old lady sitting in our row.
Clutching her heart, she
moans, "My pills! My pills!"
prompting Catherine to
rummage through her handbag.
The old lady warns my sister who's crying
as she searches for the medicine
to take off the Jewish star
hanging on a slim gold
chain around her neck.
The purser who still thinks
a man and woman are fighting
with each other and he runs
after them clapping a hand
on the man's shoulder, the
man turns, points his gun
and shouts, "Get back! Get back!"
"Oh my God," the purser cries out.
"I don't believe it."
Just in front of the curtain that leads
to the first class cabin,
the man and woman turn to
face the passengers shouting,
"Hijack! Hijack!"
People speak urgently if quietly,
some exchanging phone numbers and pledging
to notify family members
should only some of us survive.
Soon a woman's voice comes
over the loud speaker,
which I record this way in my diary.
"Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
I'm the new pilot who has taken
command of your TWA flight.
Keep calm.
Please cooperate and put
your hands behind your head."
Catherine and I copy the
other passengers raising arms
and lacing fingers.
I wonder why the woman doesn't
tell us to put our hands
over our heads the way robbers do,
but she isn't trying to
prevent the passengers
from drawing weapons.
Instead, she needs all
of us to brace for impact
in case something goes
wrong in the cockpit.
The landing is a greaser,
very smooth with no damage
to the aircraft.
Local time is 6:40 PM about
a quarter hour before sunset,
I let Catherine appraise the situation.
Leaning past me, she peers out
the window at billows of dust
and sand, which look like smoke.
Commandos on the ground have
fashioned a makeshift runway
by lining up barrels filled
with sand and diesel-soaked rags
and the blazing torches light
up people in military uniforms
which make it look like a war.
Someone props a ladder
from the back of a truck
up to the planes front exit.
People dressed in fatigues,
ascend the ladder,
armed with flashlights and rifles,
lanterns and machine guns.
Some are boys no more
than 14 or 15 years old
and some are young women with short hair.
The men and women who took
over our flight climbed down,
triumphant heroes welcomed
by their comrades,
melting into the outdoor
throng never to be identified.
Listening to my captors,
I absorb both apology and explanation.
In one imprinted memory,
I watch commandos carry
thick yellow cables.
The faces of the men expressionless
as they go about their task.
Although I determine somehow
that this is dynamite,
there's no memory of accompanying emotion,
only the sense of a child
intently watching every move.
Again, I'm going to share a
couple of images with you.
You can see here two of
the three hijacked planes
in the Jordan Desert, our
TWA airliner on the left
and the Swiss airplane on the right
in between flies the Palestinian flag.
A few days later, a British
plane, BOAC would join us.
Here you can see the three
planes in the desert.
When I began writing this book,
many of my memories of the
hijacking were pleasant ones.
One day when Catherine's diary was resting
on her tray table, one of
the commandos spied the heart
she'd drawn on the back cover
with the name of the Israeli
boy she liked that summer,
eyes twinkling, the man
exclaimed, "Romantic."
Once when our captors let us outside,
one of the commandos joined the children
in a game of jump rope, belt clanging
and military boots thumping.
Another day sitting in the
shade under an airplane wing,
someone started a round of John Denver's,
"Leaving on a Jet Plane,"
which the folk trio, Peter,
Paul, and Mary had made into
a hit single that year.
Loud voices among the singing
hostages changed the words
to living on a jet plane,
which Catherine and I
thought was hilarious
and everyone was laughing
as we sang the line,
"Don't know when I'll be back again."
In the book I write about
the time in my adult life,
when I began to think
about the hijacking again.
It began right after 9/11
and here I hasten to add
that there's no straight line
from the 1970 hijackings to 9/11.
After all, the Popular Front
was a Marxist-Leninist organization,
they were not Muslim Jihadists.
Nonetheless, a day of multiple hijackings,
understandably unburied
memories and feelings.
Soon after 9/11, I was on
my way to the University
of Michigan to give a lecture.
I alerted my host that
I reserved the right
to turn around on the jet way
if I couldn't bring myself
to board the plane.
A warning she accepted without question.
There was no need to reveal anything more
since in October 2001,
people all over the world
were afraid to fly.
Some on the flight cried
quietly, others prayed visibly.
For the first time in 30 years,
other people were acting the
way I always felt on airplanes,
and that's when memories of
the hijacking began to intrude.
Right away, I wrote down
everything I could conjure.
It was all murky and there wasn't much.
And for the first time
ever, I wanted to know more.
Telling the stories of our own lives.
How can we answer the questions
we think to ask later on
after the passage of so much time?
Historian by trade, I wanted
to do more than excavate
just my own memories.
With a scholar's passion
for evidence and accuracy,
I wanted to compare
recollections, compare documents,
and compare recollections and
documents with each other.
As a hostage, I had quelled
memories and emotions.
As a historian, I wanted to
search for facts and feelings
to provide meaning for everything
that had happened to me
and my family.
I dug farther into my own memories
and I put my memories
together with Catherine's.
I began to talk with my elderly parents,
taking note of my father's
carefully scripted stories,
my stepmother's more nuanced versions,
and my mother's misty memories.
I found mementos my father had
saved, some in my old room,
some in his self-storage
unit over on 11th Avenue.
I talked with childhood friends,
rekindling snuffed out conversations
about a topic I hadn't
mentioned in decades.
I asked friends from high school,
college and beyond if
I'd ever even told them
I'd been hijacked.
I visited archives, read news coverage,
and watched television broadcasts.
I read the manifestos of my captors
and listened to their
narratives, past and present.
I met and conversed with fellow hostages.
I went back to the places
where everything happened.
I wondered, if I researched
the hijacking as a historian,
could that stamp out the absurd sensation
that none of it had ever
happened to me at all?
Could recovering the feelings
that accompanied the hijacking
make real something that felt so unreal.
Inside the plane, I had my diary with me
and I wrote every day,
setting down a little
over a thousand words
during my desert sojourn.
Historians prize personal writings
that date from the time and
place under investigation.
And when I started out,
I was confident that my diary
would be my trusted scaffolding
and in the moment account of
everything that came to pass
along with my thoughts and
feelings up in the air,
in the desert at release and upon return.
In 1970, I named my journal Claire,
writing my entries in the form of letters.
In that technique, I copied Anne Frank,
who began her diary
entries with "Dear Kitty."
Anne Frank and I both wanted to be writers
and her birthday was the same as mine.
With a combination of ingenuousness
and self-consciousness,
I could be an observant 12-year-old,
but rereading my diary
so many years later,
it became clear that during
that week in September,
I had constrained my
powers of observation.
So much happened that I never recorded.
It was as if I'd named my
diary Claire, meaning clear,
as a way to fool myself
that I wrote my entries
with any transparency.
I never wrote about the gun I saw
in the co-pilot's neck up in the air.
I never wrote about the
commandos I watched wiring
or are playing with dynamite
the night we landed.
I never wrote about the time
one of the women commandos
pointed her gun straight at me.
When my history students work
with first-person historical
documents, whether diaries,
letters or courtroom testimony,
I prompt them to ask, "Why did this person
tell this story this way?"
Rereading my diary while writing the book,
I saw that the aspiring
writer in me had constructed
not a full record, but
instead a tolerable story.
Not an honest story, but instead a story
I could tell when I got home.
That narrative of omissions
would comprise my version
of the hijacking and I would
carry it with me for years
and years afterward.
Unsurprisingly then in
the course of my research,
I became aware of
aspects of the hijacking,
far less pleasant than
much of what I remembered.
For one thing, there was a
stream of weapon-laden visitors
who filed up and down the
narrow aircraft aisle.
Some pointed to the hostages and laughed.
Others acted like tourists
taking in the sights,
prompting one among us to joke
that we were the main attraction
at the Jordanian branch
of the Bronx Zoo.
Within sight two were
tanks and heavy artillery,
a reporter described, quote,
"manned anti-aircraft and anti-tank guns"
in trenches dug round the three aircraft
and a big detachment of guerrillas
armed with submachine guns
and hand grenades standing on the alert.
We were surrounded in turn
by Jordanian army troops
signaling our position in a war
between Jordan and Palestinian insurgents.
Besides the guns and
grenades, and armaments,
there was the dynamite
and a shifting deadline.
A representative from the
International Red Cross
came on board one day to
assure us that in his words,
the entire world knows
what's going on here
and that everyone was
working on a solution.
He then candidly added, we
don't know if we will succeed.
Sometimes the commandos would tell us,
we cannot wait forever and you
will all go to a fiery death
if this thing isn't settled soon.
Holocaust survivors among the
hostages face their own demons
with confinement and weaponry
stirring up unbidden memories
only intensified by the
troublesome construction
of Arabs as the new Nazis.
One woman 38 years old
had gone to Bergen-Belsen
in a cattle car.
Her father was murdered
in Buchenwald and 10 aunts
and uncles died in Auschwitz.
Her captivity inside the
hijacked plane brought me,
she would say later in her broken English,
"All the memories again,
back from concentration camp,
which was a very big nightmare."
Writing the book I set out
to discover the contours
of the demands of our captors,
something I didn't entirely
understand at the time.
Sifting through communications preserved
in the Richard Nixon Presidential
Library in California
some marked "Top Secret."
In the State Department
archives in Washington,
in the Swiss Federal Archives
and the British National Archives,
I set out to make sense
of the negotiations
for our release or its opposite.
A document in the Nixon library
quoted a spokesman saying
the Popular Front had
brought explosives on board,
ready to quote, "destroy the planes"
along with their prisoners
should the demands
of the Popular Front not
be met by the deadline.
I studied the document
with care to be sure
I understood everything correctly.
The spokesman quote, "hedged
when asked if the passengers
would be permitted to get off first,
but gorilla sources said
the plan was apparently
to blow up the hostages, also," unquote.
The commando's ultimatum was
repeated in another telegram,
quote, "Time period for
meeting all of the demands
is 72 hours.
If demands are not met within this time,
planes with all passengers
will be blown up."
A Swiss official described by
a colleague as level-headed
and not given to emotional talk
noted the serious possibility
of, quote, "a bloodbath"
in the desert.
The weapons and the
dynamite and the deadline,
when I returned home I would say,
I didn't really think about that.
During my research,
as I learned more about
my fellow hostages,
I also discovered something else
that my sister and I were different
from most of the other
American Jews on our plane.
My father's parents were in
the words of his brother,
world-class, non-practicing Jews.
On my mother's side,
my grandmother had refashioned herself
from Libby Yetta to Lily Yvette.
As part of that transformation,
she spoke with an
effective British accent,
prepared ham for Sunday
dinner and bought Easter hats
for her granddaughters.
Our reason for traveling to Israel
also made my sister and me different.
This was only three
years after the 1967 war
when American Jews flocked to Israel,
happily visiting the
territories rested from Jordan,
the old city of Jerusalem,
including the Western
wall and the holy sites
of Hebrew and Jericho, and
Bethlehem on the West Bank.
No one ever took Catherine
and me to those sites,
and the only reason we
were going to Israel
was to visit our mother.
In the words of one dance historian,
though of Jewish extraction,
Linda Hodes, my mother
had never been interested
in Israel or Zionism.
When my mother and Israeli
stepfather took my sister
and me to visit friends in
the artist colony of Ein Hod,
we had no idea that the
hundreds of Palestinians there
in 1948 had been exiled to refugee camps,
the village soon resettled
by Israeli artists.
In the letter, "Home to our
Father," Catherine wrote,
"Painters, printers,
and sculptors live there
in quaint little Arab style houses,
enraptured and entirely
unaware of the history
she was describing.
Everywhere are beautiful
mountain views and flowers,"
she wrote.
I had no idea that Palestinians
had once lived in Israel
because many Jews in
1970 had no idea either.
The historian, Omar Bartov,
whose elders made their way
from eastern Europe to
Palestine lived, he wrote,
next to quote-unquote,
"abandoned" Palestinian villages.
But as a child, he never once,
those are his words, considered
the origins of those ruins,
nor did the Israeli kids we played with
have anything to teach us on this count.
Israeli writer, Ari Shavit around my age,
noted that his grandparents
and parents proceeded
with their lives as if Palestinians
quote, "never existed."
Catherine and I were aware
that our captors wanted us
to empathize with them
and we were interested
in the stories they told.
This is how we live every day.
This is all we have to eat.
We have no homes.
And once again said the
aviator in the Little Prince,
without understanding why I
had a queer sense of sorrow.
Children trying to make
sense of global politics
in human terms, Catherine
and I stirred the new history
we had learned in the desert
into the history we already knew
and stirred the pain of our
captors into our own fears
and the fears of our fellow hostages.
In Israel, our friend's
parents had taken refuge
from the Holocaust,
witnessed the death of family
and the loss of homes in Europe,
escaping the destruction
of the Jewish people.
Our captors, who bore no
responsibility for the Holocaust,
had in turn lost their homes in Palestine,
many of them raised in refugee camps.
History was the key,
yet each side told completely
different histories.
"What are your feelings
toward the guerrillas now?"
My father would ask when we got home,
and I have this conversation on tape.
"The Palestinians,"
Catherine corrects him.
No anger, no resentment.
My voice comes on the tape.
They have some type of
point which I didn't know
before I offer.
"They have something
they're really trying to say
and they need to say it.
It's pretty sad."
My sister continues.
I was very naive about
the political aspect.
I learned more, a lot
more than I knew before.
Their purpose was to get back
their home, she explains,
and the plea of any people's
to get back their home
is a valid plea.
My sister and I puzzled out the question,
could Israelis and Palestinians
live on the same land?
Maybe it had once been
possible, we thought,
but there was so much anger now,
so much hatred that it
didn't seem possible anymore.
We couldn't think of a solution.
"I stopped in my tracks,
my heart torn asunder,
but still I did not
understand," said the aviator
in Little Prince.
There in the desert,
Catherine and I just
felt sorry for everyone.
Now in part, the book traces
my journey toward understanding
that my sister and I had really been there
inside that plane in the
desert, held hostage for a week.
In the National Archives in Washington,
I watched raw news footage
preserved by the CIA
of our release.
Though at the time,
Catherine and I didn't know
where we were going,
where we were being taken
or what would happen next.
It was early afternoon
when we arrived in a van
at the Intercontinental
Hotel in Amman, Jordan.
Watching the tapes, I see
some of what I remembered.
Soldiers direct our vehicle,
a commando holds a megaphone.
Horns honk, people speak in Arabic.
13 minutes in the tape switches
to the inside of the van.
Passengers displaying
expressionless caution.
A photographer had thrust
his camera straight
into one of the open
windows, and there we are,
and I'll show you an image.
Here's a still photograph.
I sit impassively hand
to cheek, shielding me,
partly obscuring me, Catherine
looks straight into the lens,
serious, responsible, afraid.
On the tape, she twists around
to look out the windows,
scanning the commotion,
planning what to do,
thinking how can I keep
us from being separated?
How can I keep Martha safe?
Tentatively then on the tape,
I look around too.
Right there on the screen before my eyes
is the 12-year-old girl
I've been trying to conjure.
But there's that feeling again.
Despite all the documents,
despite all the fellow hostages
I've met and talked to,
many of whom after all don't
remember Catherine and me.
There's the feeling that the
hijacking must have happened
to someone else.
Studying the moving image of that girl
makes me feel more than
anything else like a historian
coming upon a visual representation
of her long research
subject for the first time.
Watching the tape all those
years later I write down,
I can't believe I was there.
I'm going to dedicate this next passage
about our arrival at
Kennedy Airport to my father
who died at the age of 98,
before he had a chance to read the book.
Of course, I could have
given him the manuscript
at any point, but I never did.
I see my father before he sees us.
He's so pale that the words white
as a sheet leap into my mind.
Then he sees us and bolts forward,
and Catherine sees him too.
His expression changing
instantly from grave
to beaming now waving at us wildly.
He breaks into a run and so do we.
The scene I'd imagined so
many times coming to life.
My father folds his arms around both of us
at the same time.
"Oh dad," Catherine says, "we
were so worried about you."
My stepmother stands by astonished
that the two of us are so calm.
In her words, "no crying,
no tears, ready to go."
"Nothing about him," said the aviator
in the Little Prince gave any
suggestion of a child lost
in the middle of the desert.
Decades later researching
the book, I asked my father,
"Did you ever think we were going to die?"
"No," he says, right away,
"I always knew you were coming back,
not for a second." He tells
me, did he think otherwise?
My stepmother remembers
it differently though.
She describes my father
during those days and nights
as a man on another planet
at one stoic, frozen,
and devastated.
Was he thinking of never
getting you back? She says.
Well, yes.
Killed and never coming back? Oh, yes.
And the last bit I'll share
this afternoon takes place
in the summer of 2019.
"So this is your first
official visit to Jordan?"
Says our guide, Salah Layfat
trim in his blue jeans
and short sleeve green shirt.
Though his degrees in economics,
Salah has a special interest in travelers
who care about history and politics.
The makeshift desert
airstrip no longer exists
now buried beneath the buildings
of a recently constructed defense plant.
At the security station
that blocks the entrance,
men emerge, shake hands, speak in Arabic.
I can see Salah gesturing
toward me explaining
why I'm there.
He comes back to the car
to say that the plant
is a completely restricted area,
that it's impossible to gain entry.
The security men have
given Salah directions
to an unrestricted high
point, and we head south,
then west, our driver pulling
onto a narrow paved road,
then a dirt road until we come
to a stop near a trash dump
with feral dogs scrounging
in the detritus.
It's 8:30 in the morning
and it's already hot
as we crunch across the powdery lime
that covers our shoes in white dust.
"You were on your way back to
the place where you landed?"
The aviator asked a little prince.
"At your time in 1970, this
was just desert," Salah says.
Almost 50 years later,
I stand on the ledge
looking north over a
flat, expansive scrub,
a steel factory and parts
of a petroleum refinery rise
to our west.
The newest part of the city of
Zarqa spreads out behind us.
"The sand, I think would be
in that area," Salah says,
pointing to a low ridge
and the hills farther on.
Then you don't remember
said the little prince,
this is not the exact spot.
Comparing the coordinates
of the satellite image
to a cell phone compass,
Bruce, my husband with me that day,
determines that we're less
than half a mile away.
We're standing on the crest
where reporters coming
from a Amman caught sight
of a three airplanes
laid out like children's toys
or three dots on a domino.
Envisioning Catherine and
me, two young hostages,
Bruce loses his composure
behind his sunglasses.
An occasional brush of wind
relieves the solid morning heat,
which suddenly seems familiar.
"I remember that it was
hot like this," I say.
The airplane doors were open
and sometimes the breeze would come in.
Bruce is taking pictures
panning with his camera.
"Take your time guys,
not to rush," Salah says.
You can tag the photos with your location.
"Yes, there'll be GPS tagged," Bruce says,
steadying his voice.
This is where the sun came up,
he observes pointing to the east.
After such a nightmare, Salah says,
"To come back and see the place
where these things happened is something."
This is the advantage of
being a child at that time
because you hadn't any
idea about what's going on.
We stood on that ledge for a
little more than half an hour.
"Look at it carefully, so that
you will be sure to recognize
it in case you travel
someday to the desert."
Said the aviator in the Little Prince.
I'm ready to leave.
The thought comes to me,
I don't ever need to come back here again.
I say, "It feels like it
happened to someone else."
Thank you for listening.
- Thank you, Martha.
That was wonderful.
And if I can just say, you know,
I had heard Martha give
talks from the book
and I had discussed it with her,
and I really wasn't
prepared for how moving
I found the book to be
as I read it this summer.
You know, I knew it was gonna
be fascinating historically,
but it's just an incredibly gripping read
and it's also just very,
very moving for in ways
that I'd like to try to get at today.
And in fact, the first question,
so I encourage everyone to
please send in questions
using the Q&A function at
the bottom of your screen.
And we already have a couple questions,
so I'm gonna dive right in.
The first one, your eloquence and calmness
in presenting the terrifying
events is striking to me.
I imagine that the experience contributed
to a kind of emotional distance.
My question, did the
experience of writing the book
bring more emotion to
your recall of the events?
And that is having read the book,
that is in a way what
you're after in a sense,
but could you talk about that?
- Yeah, it's such a wonderful question.
Thank you.
Writing the book was hard.
It was hard for me emotionally.
I was a fellow at the
Cullman Center for Scholars
and Writers when I
began writing this book.
And I had a wonderful support
of a cohort of fellows
who are writing different kinds of works,
nonfiction, fiction, history, poetry.
And at the end of our fellowship year,
I'll just share this story,
one of the fellows who was
a very emotional person
and who would often, you know,
she would cry in the middle of
a conversation or at lunches.
And so she joked at the
end of the fellowship year,
I think I'm the fellow
who's cried the most
during this year.
And then I said to her,
"Well, that's if you
don't count crying alone
in our offices."
So writing was very hard.
Publishing the book was hard.
It was also hard for my sister
who was so incredibly
supportive and amazing
during the whole process
and read the manuscript.
Talking about it, it's so
interesting talking about it.
I have to, in a way,
assume that kind of calm,
I don't know if I'd call it detached,
but I have to be the writer
talking to an audience.
But I've also found that
since the book came out,
I've experienced other
kinds of emotional troubles.
And you know, we always think of memoirs
as somehow solving past anxieties.
And I almost found it to be the opposite.
Writing the book was, I'm
really glad I wrote the book
and I'm really glad I researched the book,
and that my sister shared
the experience with me,
but having the book come out
and having the book be out
is actually quite difficult.
So the questioner is correct
that my demeanor is, you know,
something that I'm very
conscious of having to assume
when I talk to groups and
talk to readers and people,
which I very much want to do
and very much enjoy doing.
So thank you for that question.
- And another one,
you said it felt like it
happened to someone else,
and that's a striking sentence.
As a historian, would
you say that you've tried
to help people feel like
things happen to them?
- Also, a wonderful question, thank you.
And I say it's a wonderful question
because I wanted to write a book
that somebody could
read without having had
the same kind of traumatic
experience I had.
And that it could speak to people who,
maybe especially people to
whom things had happened
as children that they were not encouraged
to talk about at the time,
things they didn't understand
that happened to them as children.
And now of course, we're grownups
and we can go back and try to make sense
of some of the things that happened to us.
And what I found was in
a very gratifying way,
I have received messages from readers
who experienced very different
kinds of very sad events
as young people, quite a few
from people who lost a parent
as a young child and some in
very traumatic circumstances.
One from a reader who
was a very young child
in a car accident that killed her mother,
but she was a survivor
and nobody ever talked to her about it.
I also received an incredibly,
incredibly moving message
from somebody who had
been violently assaulted
in an incident that he
named as gay bashing,
he's in the hospital for four months
and wrote in this message that
although, you know, he said,
they fixed me up pretty well physically,
he was still trying to
deal with it emotionally.
And all of these messages said,
you know, your book helped
me think about these things
I didn't wanna think about before.
Or some of them were from people who said,
your book reminded me of the process
that I went through when I, at first,
didn't want to think about
things and then turn to them.
And so that was really important to me
that the book could transcend
its particular trauma
and topic and speak to
readers in that way.
- Yeah, that's what I mean.
I lost a parent very young
and then very quickly decided
that, you know, that was
something I had moved on
and that that was the part
that really resonated for me,
you know, that you went back to school,
and acted like everything was okay,
and I remembered something very similar.
I'm wondering whether
the kind of work on trauma
was important to you
as you wrote this and specifically,
the idea of kind of delayed
onset PTSD and you know,
Freud talks about the
concept of Nachträglichkeit
and a kind of, where, as I understand it,
a subsequent event can trigger
a feeling of trauma
related to an earlier event
that you didn't necessarily
register as trauma at the time.
And it made me think of
your experience of 9/11
as that kind of second event here.
I'm wondering if any of
that kind of trauma theory
was important to you?
- Yeah, so I have a big long bibliography
in the back of the book and
readers who skimmed through it
will see that I read many,
many professional journal
articles from psychology
and psychiatry journals about trauma.
What was tough was that very few,
really none of the articles were based on
the kinds of experiments or circumstances
that replicated our own.
So articles about trauma and children
are usually about sexual abuse
or witnessing an accident,
something like, those
were two common phenomena
that were often in these articles.
There is one wonderful
writer and psychologist
who wrote quite extensively about children
who were on a hijacked school bus.
And although it was very different,
her work was very important to me.
So that was incredibly important to me,
and I did learn from it,
but it's also important,
and I do write about this
in the book that, you
know, PTSD was not named
until 10 years after the hijacking.
It was named in 1980.
Now of course, it happened,
and you know, I'm a Civil War historian,
people talked about
soldiers and shellshock,
and all of that kind of,
obviously, people were aware of it,
but it wasn't named.
And what I noticed in doing my research
was that all kinds of authorities
spoke about the event,
kind of like you were
saying a moment ago, Maury,
about your mother as if
it's over and that's fine.
And so I was astounded to
hear a newscaster just say
the words, and now
their nightmare was over
when we got home.
I also found that I very much
took on that narrative myself.
So one of my favorite
examples during my research
was my best friend in
Israel was kind enough
to share with me the letters
that she and I had written
to each other after we got home.
And in one of them I wrote to her,
it was the first letter I
wrote to her after I got home.
And I, you know, wrote her a few things,
didn't say anything about the hijacking.
And then I said, I'll
write you a longer letter
when more things have happened, you know,
as if nothing had happened.
And so I also talked to friends of mine,
I was entering the seventh grade
who I talked to friends
of mine in seventh grade
what their memories were?
And one of them said
very, very poignantly,
she said to me, the
impression that the girls
in your class had was,
these are her words,
"no harm done, no lasting effect."
So I was very determined not to absorb
what had happened to me.
And that was the way for me to prove,
I believe now to prove its
insignificance to myself.
And part of it was about
protecting my parents.
I didn't want them to
know that I had suffered
because I knew that they had suffered.
So, you know, this is
the challenge of writing
about childhood trauma
and childhood memories,
and all of that was part of the process
of researching the book, writing the book,
and then also thinking about
the book since its publication.
- Okay, we have quite
a lot of questions now.
So one, so you talk about how
Holocaust survivors experience
the hijacking.
Do you make the distinction
about being a young Jew
having this experience versus
elderly people repeating
a trauma that was particularly Jewish?
- Yeah, that's a really
interesting question.
I wouldn't say for sure.
I mean, you can read the
book in different ways.
I think in my reading,
the only way I make that distinction
is by saying that my sister and I knew
there were Holocaust
survivors on the plane
and they had often been
children during the Holocaust.
We didn't know them well,
but we knew that was true
because we heard people talking about it
and that we felt very sorry for them.
Now, as I said in my talk,
we also felt sorry for our
captors who had been children
when their families had lost their homes.
And so in a way,
and I think I said the line from the book,
we felt sorry for everyone.
And of course, I did talk about, you know,
that my sister and I were
different from other American Jews
on the plane.
So in a way I was 12, my sister was 13,
we were trying to make
sense of all of this.
I think we were empathic
children in our own ways.
And so I don't believe
I made a distinction
in the way the questioner asked
and it's a very interesting distinction.
It was more a matter
of trying to understand
the circumstances of
different people in our midst,
captors and captives.
And again, kind of wanting to
solve everybody's problems,
but not being able to
think of a way to do that.
And the last thing I'll say,
and I'll try to keep my responses short
because there are many questions, but...
Oh, I'm sorry, nevermind.
I don't even remember
what I was gonna say.
- Yeah, I mean, I do feel
like there are those moments
in the book where, you know,
I don't think this is my own
projection of the reading
where you're talking about,
especially in the part,
the, you know, where they ask
you whether you're Jewish,
the hijackers, and that did,
I think, I'm not imagining this,
that you bring up that in
relation to the holocaust
in the book.
- Yeah,
so I'd like to just say
a little bit about that.
It's very important.
There was the second night we're
on the plane, Monday night,
that was the one time where
the commandos questioned
the hostages and asked each
hostage if they were Jewish.
And my sister answered
for us, and she said yes.
And then what happened that
night was quite frightening,
was the most frightening
moment of the whole hijacking
where, you know, people were
taken outside to the desert.
It was nighttime and you know,
there were armed commandos around us.
And then what ultimately happened was
a fair number of hostages were released.
From our plane, the only
people who were released
were not Jewish.
The fact is the Jews
whose names were called
were sent back to the plane,
but very important,
and I discovered this during my research,
there were still many, many
non-Jews who were on the plane
and who were retained the whole week.
And our captors also kept
about 50 hostages longer
for two weeks longer.
And about two thirds of
those people were not Jewish.
And also the same night
that some of the non-Jews
from our plane, the TWA
plane were sent on to Amman,
Jews from the Swiss
airplane were released.
And that Swiss airplane had
not made a stop over in Israel.
And people surmise that
might have been why.
So what I write about in the book
is one of the enduring
myths of this hijacking
is that our captors
separated Jews from non-Jews,
held all the Jews and
let all the non-Jews go.
And that's simply not true.
But I do concede that it
was a frightening moment
on Monday night and a confusing moment
and that's, I think why that myth endured.
You know, I also should
say that after that night,
and, you know, this
isn't just my analysis,
but this is from my research,
there was never any
distinction made between Jews
and non-Jews.
Our captors did make a distinction
between Jews and Zionists,
and they were very clear about that.
And occasionally when they
would interrogate people,
they would ask them about
their views of Zionism
because that was a way,
so what they were trying to do
when they were asking these
questions was to determine
who would be a valuable
hostage to hold longer
because they wanted to
exchange their hostages
for Palestinian prisoners.
So a complicated, complex situation.
And I feel strongly, and I
do set this out in the book,
that all the facets of
it need to be understood.
- And they also, as I remember,
were very interested in certain Americans,
especially on your plane,
there was an African American
like who was in the army maybe
who was kept the whole time.
And there were two maybe people...
Anyway, yeah, you-
- Yeah, so some of the other
hostages you're referring to
an African American soldier,
a man named Leonard Kane,
who was kept longer.
And also, I think you're
probably referring
to there were two
diplomats, either of them
were Jewish.
- Who eats,
one of them eats like a secret message.
- Yeah, so there was, I
didn't know this at the time,
but what I learned was up in
the air while the hijacking
was taking place, these were
two state department officials
and one of them had his
notes, some notes with him.
And you know, just as a
kind of diplomat sphere,
he ended up ripping
them into little pieces
and swallowing them.
And, you know, I read that in one source
and then it was corroborated
because historians always
wanna corroborate stories.
In another source in which a woman told me
that her eight-year-old
son said her up in the air,
"Mom, why are those men
behind us eating paper?"
So I knew that that had happened.
So people were kept for different reasons.
The hijackers were also interested
in Americans on our plane
who had dual Israeli citizenship.
And there were actually very few of those.
And one of the reasons
they were so interested
was because one of the
other hijackings that day
had been an El Al plane that
did take off from Israel.
And there were of course,
many Israelis on that plane.
And there was a real
dearth of Israeli citizens
that they could leverage to
trade for Palestinian prisoners.
And so they trained their
sites on dual citizens,
of which there were actually
very few on our plane.
- And you write about how
your sister answered for you
when they asked if you were
Jewish and she decided to say
that you were Jewish,
but she didn't totally tell the truth
that you were visiting your
mother who lived in Israel,
right?
- Yes, that's exactly right.
So she said we were Jewish.
And then one of the questions
that they also asked each
hostage that evening was,
why were you in Israel?
And what my sister said was,
we are visiting our grandparents.
Now, my grandparents did
live in Israel that summer,
and that was true,
but something stopped her from bringing up
that our mother lived there.
It felt too close and a
little too frightening to her.
And I think she felt, you know,
she had no intention about
lying about being Jewish,
but she wasn't lying to
say that we were visiting
our grandparents, she just
wasn't telling the whole story.
- And that might have been smart
because then they might have assumed
that you were dual nationals in some way-
- They might have.
I mean, it's interesting
you're quite right.
The fact is, and I do write
about this in the book,
our captors were quite kind
to the children on the plane.
That was not the experience
of all of the grownups
by any means, especially the
ones who were interrogated,
which happened by the way,
at night when we were asleep.
And I had no idea this had happened
until I was researching later.
But they let us outside
for air and exercise,
they jumped rope with us,
they sang songs with us.
They gave little kids piggyback rides.
You know, we're in the
middle of the desert,
we can see water on the horizon
'cause it was a mirage.
And I had just learned about
mirage's in sixth grade,
and one of the commandos, you
know, knelt down on the sand
and explained the scientific
workings of mirages
to a group of children.
So they were not personally
frightening to us as children.
- Yeah, so this, you've answered,
some people have asked questions
about whether your
recollections were different
from the other passengers,
I think that answers.
Here's an interesting question.
You speak sensitively about
the events that influenced
the hijackers political views.
In what ways do you think
your experience helped shape
what I take to be your political views
of the Israeli-Palestinian conflict?
- Yeah, it's such an interesting question.
You know, don't forget
that I never thought
about the hijacking for
years and years, and years.
When I was researching, I mean,
I knew obviously, I was
up on current events
in terms of Israel-Palestine,
I would say my sister,
who was only a year and
a half older than I,
and just so smart and so savvy.
I feel like she...
So the thing about my
sister, which is so amazing,
and this is in the book,
is she was so keen to be,
to never to deny how
incredibly frightening
and traumatic this experience was.
She would never deny that
I was the one denying that.
She also was simultaneously
able to hold in her mind
and in her heart, this incredible
empathy for our captors.
And she does that in a way that's unusual
and very human and very admirable.
And I think in some ways, I did that too,
but I did it by
suppressing much more ideas
about my feelings about fear.
And then when I, you know,
really began to research
the Popular Front, I
mean, look, first of all,
you know, the Popular Front
was a revolutionary minority
within the PLO in 1970.
And the rest of the members of the PLO,
which made up of many
factions in many groups,
did not support the tactic
and strategy of hijacking.
And they were quite
infuriated with the PFLP.
So we can't take the
PFLP as representative
of Palestinian views at the time,
they were looked on with disfavor
by fellow Palestinian insurgents.
Nonetheless, you know,
researching all of that
and all of that context,
I think it clarified for
me some of my own views
about the situation in the Middle East,
which as a historian,
the last thing I'll say,
you know, historians,
we thrive on complexity and you know,
the trouble with many dialogues
about Israel-Palestine
is that neither side wants
to face the complexity.
And so I try to do that in the book,
and maybe the fact that
people on both sides
have been disappointed with
the book in certain ways,
or maybe I should say the
extremes of both sides.
People have been disappointed
that I wasn't straight out
pro-Israel and, you know,
in all of my renderings
of this event and others were disappointed
that I wasn't more sympathetic
to the Palestinian plight.
I don't think it's that
I'm not taking a stand,
but I think it's that
I'm trying to present
the nuance and the complexity,
and that's hard to do.
- So someone writes,
both you and your sisters seem to have had
a dispassionately mature
response to the hijacking
at the time you were
considering the plight
of the hijackers, did you later experience
PTSD in the sense and has,
I think I know the answer
to this, has the experience
altered your views
on terrorism or hijacking,
you know, generally?
- Yeah, I mean, so, you
know, PTSD wasn't named,
but it doesn't mean it didn't exist.
And so I read about the symptoms
and I read about these conditions.
My sister and I would
not have been diagnosed
with PTSD when we came home.
We would've been diagnosed with something
called acute stress disorder,
which is much more short-lived.
So we did, we had bad dreams and you know,
we had certain symptoms that
absolutely did affect us,
but some people would have been,
many people would've
been diagnosed with PTSD,
but not everybody.
So that's the first thing.
I should also say that I had
and still have, despite
researching and writing this book,
flying on airplanes,
which I do very frequently
is still very difficult for me.
And, you know, still
engenders a lot of anxiety.
So I completely willing to admit that.
And tell me the second
part of the question again.
- Yeah, did it change your view
of terrorism and hijacking?
- No, I mean-
- It seems like 9/11
is a motivating factor of
your writing the book, right?
- Yes, I mean, it's so interesting
because the word terrorism
is a complicated word.
And I'm just gonna say a word about this
because I am historian,
I care about the historical
use of that word.
And you know, experts disagree
on the use of that word.
And historians puzzle out
the history of the word.
And I was very interested
to find that in 1970,
the mainstream press, so
like the New York Times
did not use the word
terrorists much at all.
So just-
- They used guerrillas, right?
Didn't they call-
- Guerrillas,
and so the words I use in the book,
I do use commandos, guerrillas, captors,
I use all of those words.
Just to give one example,
there's a New York Times headline
from September 10th, 1970 that reads,
"Popular Front, most
militant commando group."
So, you know, and that was,
I got the word commando
actually not from my captors,
but from the press.
And I wanted to be historically accurate.
And you know, people have written about
the trajectory of the word terrorism,
you know, the hard part
about the word terrorism
is for whom do you use it and
for whom do you not use it?
And so, you know, the leader and founder
of the Popular Front
Liberation of Palestine,
George Habash, who by
the way, was Christian,
was not Muslim.
You know, he would say that terrorism was,
and these are his words, "was
what made of us refugees."
So it's a complicated term.
I mean, obviously, I didn't condone 9/11
or the Munich Olympics,
or what happened at Tybee,
or any of those things.
And you know, even when we came home
and I have this conversation on tape,
and somebody asked my father, you know,
how do you feel about the guerrillas,
I think is what the questioner said.
And my father said, "You know,
sympathetic to their cause,
but not to their strategy and tactics."
And so that also I think
was meaningful to me
that my father could say
those words at the time.
- Okay, we're almost out of time.
I'm gonna take the privilege of asking you
the last question myself,
which is a very interesting
part in the book
where you cite the hijackers saying
that they were anti-Zionist,
but not anti-Semitic or
anti-Jewish, I think.
And you know, this of course,
is one of the main questions
facing anti-Semitism studies now,
when does anti-Zionism
turn into anti-Semitism?
I'm just wondering if you
could explain a little bit
how the hijackers saw that difference
and how you deal with it in the book?
- Yeah, so thank you for that, Maury.
The Popular Front was very
clear that they distinguished
between Jews and Zionists.
So this is what they said, I mean,
you can take it as you wish,
but it is their position papers.
Habash, who I mentioned before,
their founder and leader,
when the hijacking happened,
he had recently said to
a reporter that the PFLP
was quote, "not hostile
to the Jews as Jews
and did not aim at annihilating them
or throwing them into the sea."
So, and further quote,
"we harbor no hostility to the Jews,
but we shall fight the Zionists
because they invaded and
occupied our homeland."
Now obviously, that's
a very loaded statement
for many people.
I will say though, that
from reading interviews
with my fellow hostages,
many, some or many of them seem
to come to an understanding
of that during the week.
So, you know, one person told
a reporter, well, you know,
they like the Jews, but they
don't like the Zionists.
Or, you know, they said they
could live with the Jews
as long as they were non-Zionist.
And so, you know, that distinction isn't
one that everybody would make,
but the thing that was interesting was
when our captors asked us that
one night when they asked,
you know, what's your
religion or are you Jewish?
You know, that was something that in a way
was a tactical error.
And in the book I quote
this man, William Quandt,
who was from the National
Security Council,
who said, you know, he
put it this way he said,
"You know, the PFLP didn't go around
and ask people about
their political views,
they simply asked what
their religion was,"
which was, quote, "not
a very smart thing to do
if you're trying to combat the common view
of anti-Semitism."
And he's absolutely right.
But what is interesting
is in those I learned
during my research in the interrogations
of various adults on the plane,
they did actually ask people
their views on Zionism
as a way to determine who they felt
would be a valuable hostage.
So, you know, that I did a lot
of reading on anti-Zionism,
anti-Semitism.
I have my own view on it,
not everybody will agree,
it's quite fraught.
But I do think it was
very important for me
to read the literature of my captors,
and at least to have a sense
of what their official positions were.
And you know, I've also
talked to people who said,
you know, they shouldn't,
you know, people,
they shouldn't have
asked you that question.
It was just kind of like a
flawed human being thing to do.
Like people don't always follow
their political strategies,
you know, in the perfect way.
And I do think they
understood after that night
that it was the wrong thing to do.
So complicated, again-
- And there was also the
confusion that they would refer,
they didn't wanna say the
word Israeli sometimes
to acknowledge Israel.
So they would call people Jews,
even though they really meant Israelis.
And so that-
- Also, you know,
very confusing and
frightening to some people.
So language, I do talk
about language in the book,
and I actually, it's so
important that I invoke
a quotation from the Little
Prince talking about,
you know, I don't know
the exact quotation now,
but that language can be
confusing and can cause harm.
And so all of those aspects
made it in a way, and maybe this is,
you decide if it's an ending point,
but in a way, those
complexities and nuances
made it possible for people
to understand the event
in whatever context they
brought to it before it began.
- Yeah, so interesting.
Okay we are out of time
and I apologize to everyone
whose questions I didn't get to,
but this was such, I
think it's just a sign
that it's such a rich book
and I really urge everyone to read it.
And thank you.
You can't hear everyone clapping,
but I will clap for you.
So thank you so much, Martha,
for sharing this with us today.
- Thank you so much Maury,
and I would like to thank
the audience, all of you,
for all of your very
thought-provoking questions.
Thank you so much.
- Yeah, thank you to the audience
and I hope to see you
at future YPSA events.
So again, please check
out our calendar events
on our website and sign
up for our mailing list.
Okay, bye everybody.